[Música]
soñar
confiar
amar
y cada uno de nosotros
cada uno de nosotros que sueña
cada uno de nosotros que confía
cada uno de nosotros que ama
quizás por sí solas cada una de estas
cualidades no hace mucha diferencia no
se pueden sostener por mucho tiempo
pero cuando se unen soñar confiar y amar
cuando se unen estas tres cualidades
sucede algo maravilloso se crea una
estructura de hecho bastante fuerte
bastante firme
soñar confiar llamar
quisiera empezar con un ejercicio
bastante sencillo es un ejercicio que
nos va a ayudar a conectarnos entre
todos bueno yo ya me viene conectado
pero lo lindo de este ejercicio es que
es súper fácil es extremadamente
poderoso y no se preocupen no tienen que
quitarse los zapatos lo único que tienen
que hacer me encantaría que me acompañen
es poner la espalda recta llevar un poco
adelante el pecho y a partir de acá
acompáñenme
lo vamos a repetir dos veces más pero
quisiera que vayan prestando atención a
qué se siente en el cuerpo segunda vez
registra en lo que sienten sobre todo en
la primer mitad del movimiento una vez
más la última
perfecto
eso que acaban de hacer exactamente eso
es inspirar
suena super sencillo dice esta manera
pero es que no me parece casualidad
no me parece coincidencia que se use una
misma palabra para referirse tanto a la
inspiración fisiológica como a la
inspiración emocional la inspiración
artística la inspiración divina
y es que permite a monos descomponer la
acción para entenderle un poquito más a
fondo que estamos haciendo cuando
inspiramos estamos movilizando algo en
este caso oxígeno lo estamos jalando lo
estamos trayendo incorporando en nuestro
cuerpo y en ese proceso sostenemos la
vida ahora yo me pregunto no es acaso
exactamente lo mismo lo que siente un
artista cuando se siente inspirado
porque el artista inspirado se siente
movilizado se siente conducido se siente
guiado el mismo artista no puede
reconocer que pero siente como si algo
más grande lo estuviera absorbiendo lo
estuviera incorporando y en ese proceso
se sostiene la vida o en este caso el
arte
la inspiración es un impulso
extremadamente poderoso y es la chispa
que da inicio a este maravilloso proceso
que quiero compartir con ustedes en mi
caso ya desde niño las hazañas físicas
eran una gran inspiración una acrobacia
en el cine una pirueta en la tele yo
quedaba fascinado aún recuerdo cuando
era niño pasaba clases de artes
marciales y un día bien mi profesor
correr a toda velocidad dar un salto
increíble ponerse de forma horizontal y
conectar con las dos piernas simultáneas
a la bolsa me uno a la cabeza fue lo más
maravilloso que había visto en mi vida
y todas estas afinidades naturales o
espontáneas resultaron ser un gran
indicador años más tarde para ayudarme a
conectar con mi propósito con mi llamado
por eso me parece extremadamente
importante que le prestemos mucha
atención a todas estas señales porque no
es casualidad que a mí me guste una cosa
a usted le guste otra eso nos está
tratando de decir algo nos está tratando
de guiar hacia algún sitio y es de ahí
de donde nacen los sueños
pero yo pienso que soñar no solo se
trata de cosas concretas de metas de
objetivos yo pienso que soñar también se
trata de darse permiso
un amigo mío una persona que yo quiero
mucho administrador de empresas
excelente profesional tenía un buen
trabajo y de hecho le gustaba su trabajo
él no sufría todos los lunes llegando a
la oficina pero los que lo conocemos
sentíamos que en el fondo había algo más
para los que no saben parkour es una
disciplina física relacionada al
movimiento corporal pues este amigo
respiraba parkour soñaba parkour vivía
parkour
así que un día nos reunimos varias
personas cercanos a él debatimos durante
un par de horas y después de una intensa
conversación nos convencimos de que
renuncia a su trabajo
actualmente se podría decir que no tiene
la estabilidad de un trabajo
convencional en lugar de eso tiene su
propia escuela de parkour donde tiene la
posibilidad de expresarse en el lenguaje
que más ama donde tiene la posibilidad
de desarrollarse a sí mismo hacia sus
mejores versiones
donde tiene la posibilidad de estallar
la cabeza a sus alumnos con sus piruetas
maravillosas y lo más importante hace
que sus alumnos sueñen por eso soñar no
sólo se trata de metas de objetivos
también se trata de darse permiso
confiar
cuando yo estudiaba confluyó no era ni
cercanamente el mejor de mi clase es más
yo nunca fui a alguien particularmente
destacado por mis habilidades físicas yo
era el niño gordito que nadie quería en
el equipo
pero siempre hubo algo ahí que me atraía
de captura fuertemente de hecho me
inspiraba según la definición que
estamos manejando
así que en un momento de mi vida después
de varios intentos fallidos en carreras
convencionales decidí convertirlo en mi
carrera y aún recuerdo ese día en el que
le dije a mis padres que dejaría la
universidad para dedicarme al consumo
la cara que pusieron me dijeron cómo vas
a hacer de que vas a ganar plata
honestamente yo les digo no tenía
respuesta a esas preguntas no había
manera que yo sepas que responderles
pero ni siquiera yo sabía porque sentía
dentro mío un fuerte sentimiento de
confianza sentía que todo iba a estar
bien
y tal como en la historia de mi amigo
encontré un espacio para expresarme en
el lenguaje que más amo encontré un
espacio para desarrollarme hacia mis
mejores versiones y lo más lindo es que
sucedió lo que yo llamo un proceso de
adentro hacia afuera
y es que muchos de los jóvenes que se
encuentran en la edad de escoger sus
carreras universitarias siguen un
razonamiento cómo puedo ganar dinero y a
partir de ahí surge la opción
profesional o lo que yo llamaría de
afuera hacia adentro y honestamente
según ese razonamiento no me sorprende
que haya tantas personas que hoy en los
lunes que oyen sus trabajos
en mi caso todo empezaba con algo que me
encantaba algo que me movía
profundamente sentía que no podía vivir
sin eso
entonces
después de dejarme conducir por esta
fuerza inspiradora
después de dejarme guiar
lo voy a decir de otra forma después de
haber recibido todas las bondades que
ese camino tenía para otorgarme y
después de haber sido todo lo feliz que
ese camino podía hacerme el único
resultado posible era desear de corazón
compartir eso con más personas
llegó un punto en el que mi máximo
objetivo era lograr que otras personas
sean tan felices como yo lo era a través
de esa disciplina y entonces te vas
encontrando con personas que valoran lo
que haces que te lo quieren reconocer y
de ahí viene la equivalencia a esa
estabilidad económica de un trabajo
convencional pero el dinero nunca fue el
propósito nunca fue el objetivo central
el objetivo era otra era algo más puro y
volviendo a ese día en el que mis padres
me preguntaron cómo iba a ganar dinero
ni en mis más optimistas predicciones yo
hubiera podido calcular que la situación
se resuelva de la manera maravillosa que
lo hizo por eso fue importante lanzarse
sin tener un plan eso es o desconfiar
y por último
la cualidad que amarra a todas juntas
amara
la palabra kung fu tiene un significado
muy lindo kung fu significa habilidad o
maestría que viene como resultado del
esfuerzo de la disciplina y del trabajo
continuo
y yo nos relaciono mucho con el amor
porque para mí el amor no son las
mariposas desde el enamoramiento para mí
el amor tiene que ver con el esfuerzo
que yo le pongo a algo para merecerlo
con mis alumnos utilizo muchas veces
este ejemplo imagínense que en este
momento me estoy recibiendo campeón
mundial de la ufc y voy y guardo mi
trofeo mi título mi cinturón y me voy y
más tarde llega una persona y se lo roba
se lo lleva entonces les pregunto deje
de ser campeón
obviamente no ni yo deje de ser campeón
ni el ladrón se convirtió en el nuevo
campeón porque lo que me hace campeón no
es el título sino los años de esfuerzo
que le puse a eso
y ese razonamiento se aplica a todo
a tu trabajo a tu familia a tu pareja a
marc se trata de entregarlo todo para
construir algo
quizás el ejemplo más claro para
ilustrar este proceso de amor entrega y
esfuerzo somos nosotros mismos es
nuestro propio cuerpo porque todos
estamos familiarizados con la idea de
amarte a ti mismo pero pensamos que
amarte a ti mismo es pararte frente a un
espejo y decir yo me amo y yo me acepto
y ciertamente las afirmaciones son
importantes pero son inútiles si no
vienen acompañadas de acción de
movimiento y es ahí donde se torna
difícil es ahí donde cuestas
es por eso que nos gustan tanto estas
historias de superación donde una
persona pierde mucho peso se pone en
forma porque intrínsecamente reconocemos
que le costó mucho esfuerzo y admiramos
eso
porque perder peso por ejemplo no tienen
nada que ver con dietas con
entrenamiento con calorías tiene que ver
exclusivamente con recuperar el control
de tu propia vida con convertirte en tu
propio maestro
porque vamos por la vida pensando que
somos autónomos que controlamos nuestras
propias decisiones y es mentira cuántas
veces hemos dicho voy a hacer dieta y
una hamburguesa nos vence cuántas veces
hemos dicho voy a dejar de fumar y ese
pequeño cilindro resulta más fuerte que
nosotros
entonces es difícil es cierto requiere
paciencia requiere esfuerzo requiere
también fracasar y aceptarlo y seguir
intentando y volver a fracasar y volver
a intentarlo porque ahí está en realidad
el trabajo continuo el kung-fu el amor
no en la foto postal del resultado final
sino en el proceso
y lo lindo de aceptar el esfuerzo como
parte del proceso es que en ese punto
todo se conecta porque la confianza no
es otra cosa sino la conciencia que
tengo de mi cuerpo haciendo algo
por ejemplo en mi caso ya desde hace
muchos años yo tenía un gran sueño en mi
vida yo soñaba con un día estar parado
en un escenario que tenga esas letras
y ya desde hace años yo sentía dentro
mío la confianza de que este día iba a
llegar pero no era una confianza vacía
mucho menos una confianza arrogante era
una confianza basada en el esfuerzo
entre paréntesis amor que yo sabía que
estaba dispuesto a entregar porque sabía
que estaba dispuesto a trabajar todo lo
que sea necesario ya no rendirme nunca y
si no me aceptaba en esta oportunidad
aplicaría la siguiente ya la siguiente y
se ha ido de aquí a diez años y va a
seguir trabajando por eso y ese es es el
amor entre paréntesis el esfuerzo que
construye cosas este es el amor que
genera confianza y que sostiene los
sueños
donde se unen estos tres ejes aquí se
está tu realización personal tu punto de
máxima conexión con el universo o lo que
llamamos felicidad ese sitio en el que
todo se siente correcto incluso cuando
cuesta incluso cuando es difícil
pero la importancia de que llegues a
este punto no radica en el hecho de que
tú vas a ser feliz la importancia de
este punto es que aquí aquí tú te
conviertes en un agente extremadamente
poderoso de inspiración para tu entorno
porque de pronto una persona te voy a
hacer las cosas con el corazón y quizás
ella también se anima a soñar confiar y
amar y así se va generando esta onda
expansiva donde podemos cambiar el mundo
un trípode a la vez
lo importante de esto es que nosotros
mismos no nos imaginamos el poder que
puede tener nuestra inspiración porque
de pronto una persona me puede decir yo
no voy a cambiar el mundo peor desde mis
talentos que son algo tan sencillo
mentira ese profesor de artes marciales
de la patada voladora ni se había dado
cuenta que yo lo estaba mirando mucho
menos se daría cuenta que cambió mi vida
para siempre
y ese es el poder que puede tener una
acción que ni nosotros nos damos cuenta
de pronto puede ser que un niño nos esté
mirando hacer las cosas con pasión y lo
estemos inspirando y ese niño de aquí a
10 años resulte ser un genio creativo
importante para la historia de la
humanidad
por eso por eso es crítico que asumamos
este rol de inspiradores porque somos
nosotros
los que tenemos la posibilidad de tomar
acción y de evitar que los sistemas
colapsen
y la fórmula es sencilla ya la conocen
soñar confiar y amar gracias
[Aplausos]